yo i think i think republicans gotta
apologize to the dixie chicks okay oh
[ __ ] valid points long time coming
bro i wanna rush limbaugh once why what
happened i want [ __ ] glenn beck
because it did the dixie chicks career
and you probably know the story more
accurately yeah i mean basically that i
think they were in london and at the
time there was like a pretty big like
british like resentment to like middle
eastern intervention yeah yeah and then
they go on tour they go to irony
and they they they learn their lessons
[ __ ] high ground they learn their
lessons middle eastern intervention keep
going and so basically they go there and
they're like yo like we stand with you
guys like we completely agree we don't
want this war we don't want the violence
we don't like george bush going to the
middle east like we're ashamed of george
bush is from texas
that's what they said at the concert
yeah the baby type [ __ ] like that moment
like he'd like beat stops and they just
let it rip put your lights in there if
you don't like the war in iraq whatever
and then they got canceled by every like
republican commentator their career kind
of ended off cmt their careers they were
[ __ ] messed up they were the biggest
name of country music they're a country
group turin in london don't get radio
play to this day
they finally had a song that like this
year got radio play a little bit gas
lighter but it didn't even blow up and
they were the biggest thing in country
music for a few years and then they said
one thing we're ashamed to be from the
same state as george bush is what i
always heard as a texan yeah and then
that was it someh and it's amazing we
don't even do we even have video
evidence of this yeah i think so yeah
there was a video and now all the
republicans are like why why are we
there like this button's an idiot like
blah blah blah that's some [ __ ] like you
knew who your fans were dummies
i'm tired of these crying ass [ __ ]
like you knew who your fans were you
were showing up to the shows you saw the
flags that there was waving in the
[ __ ] crowd you made enough millions
where you were able to have a point and
be willing to lose your career and then
it was like i'm gonna i'm gonna say how
i really feel but you made your millions
first so shut your [ __ ] i think they
felt safe in england huh they felt
even more [ __ ]
say it home here
i don't know i don't i don't buy that
[ __ ] i don't buy the [ __ ] where like you
make all your money first and then you
decide that you're gonna be a good
person like roll roll the dice bro if
you really feel like it roll the dice i
don't know the history on this it was
also pretty quickly after the war it
wasn't like but the dick's chicks have
always sort of been uh like the lefties
of the country world
well then they shouldn't be canceled
right
i think that was it was the timing of it
it was post 9 11 i mean within
yeah like
o'connor doing i think yeah like we
didn't have like we didn't interview in
the movie this guy remember hearing
about this in like 2003 yeah 9 11 was
the end of 2001 so we probably went to
war 2002 and no i entered in 2003. oh so
this was quick this was quick this is
weeks after we're entering yeah for the
first round of combat is i mean we were
in that we were in there with his pops
yeah they wanted to platform to say it
then they're not going to say it
before i remember 15 years ago
we never should have did that [ __ ]
what's up houston also [ __ ] george
senior [ __ ] these [ __ ] bro
[Laughter]
you're not doing nothing brave i'm sorry
chicks
yeah yeah they deserve an apology dog
nah nah they do they do they got some
slappers bro they don't they made the
money they kissed the devil they knew
what the [ __ ] they was doing and once
they made enough money they're like i
don't want to be with the devil anymore
it's like it's like them [ __ ]
you know what i mean like yeah but i
don't think you have girlfriends that
like they're like all about being a
[ __ ] playboy bunny then they got
their own tv show and their own spin-off
they're like oh i don't want to be with
this old man anymore it's like you know
what you did yeah that i agree with but
i don't think the dixie chicks they
didn't write like a bunch of pro-america
music and then all of a sudden get money
and then be like yo [ __ ] you they just
make country music yeah then a few weeks
after we own a war they're like yo
we don't want to be a part of this [ __ ]
either they also made like lefty country
music like uh yeah so how'd they get
cancer it was it was chick [ __ ] they
yeah they absolutely just lost all their
tours they lost all their spawn no he's
saying if they were lefty then how come
they're suddenly getting canceled
because then they went too far you can
be slightly left but they weren't like
there was nothing to voice they were
apolitical yeah guys there's also
pre-social media so they didn't have any
contact with their fans
agency drugs social media maybe we would
have been like and also country music
radio which dominates oh yeah they were
off the radio they never got to tour
again no one showed up like right yeah
whatever this is what it is you know
people fans
like all these yeah they got trash they
went crazy yeah but that's also like
that political grandstanding [ __ ] like
you're using this as an opportunity and
they'll show how much you love america
they've never heard of the data and his
point mark's point is that's [ __ ]
gross especially gross now because now
you're just parroting what they were
saying basically yeah never should have
been there you [ __ ] ended these girls
careers so you could get
five minutes of your time right yeah
they had bangers the whole time yeah
yeah [ __ ] hits it's not we lost
really that's what we're saying we lost
the years of greatness the chicks yeah
yeah we got to put brittany's dad in
charge of afghanistan i think yeah yeah
we need a conservatorship in afghanistan
we really do man get brittany's dad over
there like because
they're in their head shaving face right
now you know what i mean
they're going crazy like they're like
they're kind of like off the meds a
little yeah yeah so we got to get him
what's his name again rick jamie yeah
yeah we're going to get time now he got
the time yeah
motherfucker's a psycho bro that's weird
he named his daughter named his daughter
after him oh my favorite of that is
george foreman though
georgina he's got he's got five sons all
named george yeah and then he's got one
daughter named like georgina and i maybe
think another daughter named georgetta
his 12 kids yeah and he's named over
half of them after himself yeah that's
wild but also being a dude and naming
your daughter after you is crazy yeah
like you are a crazy person yes a
narcissist that is unbelievable levels
of narcissism like you have to look at
your wife and be like i think we should
name her after me yeah and then she's
a younger daughter too yeah like he lost
the fight with the older daughter and he
was like all right i get the next one
though 100 yeah
you know what he won the fight with the
old adult yeah yeah yeah he won you
didn't let me have the name i'm gonna
have
her money wouldn't that be a set up i
knew my daughter mark 100 gotta do it
dion's daughter's name is like deandre
deon sanders some [ __ ] like that yeah
dion diandra something like that what is
that about dude i don't know
yeah the junior's just a little it's a
little a little weird a little sussy
right a little sus yo you know what i
don't think is sus
the third
i'm i'm naming my kid the third i'm
skipping i get the third i'm with you
because it's really an homage to your
father yeah it's not narcissistic you're
like i have so much respect for my dad
i'm gonna bestow his name on my child
and now this is a legacy and it all
dates back to this yes but the first
person to go junior you're a bona fide
narcissist you can also skip it though
you could just name your kid after your
dad and then he can be just yeah
you know who's a shitty father
junior is the next generation it can't
be senior and then junior and it skips
me you know who's a shitty father is the
guy who names his kid junior and then
his kid doesn't name his kid the third
yeah that's a shitty thing you know
you're looking at that guy like yeah his
name is going to be aaron [ __ ] you
yeah
i want my kid to be unique yeah i don't
want him to be anything like this
grandpa
yeah now you're the narcissist and a
shitty dad yeah if you were a narcissist
but you killed it
you knew you called your shot this kid's
gonna love me bro yes if that's their
notepad and a wallet that's their
post-it note i'm gonna be such a good
dad my kid's gonna name his kid the
third yeah that's pointing into the
stands that's baby yo right there wow
he's gonna go right there but if you do
that [ __ ] and you get it like nah bruh
it stops with me yeah you sucked dude so
what are you gonna name uh my grandkid
jake the first okay yeah yeah yeah first
you gotta hope you gotta wait so your
dad dies before you get a kid it's also
so waspy we i know a kid
i also like the nicknames coming with it
but it's so waspy the if you're the
fourth uh so fourth in line your
initials are iv and i knew a kid named
ivy
i know a couple of black thirds see i
see it as i see it as waspy or poor
like this is all i got to give exactly i
got nothing else to give you it's jethro
the seventh you're right like some real
hillbilly [ __ ] latinos you got nothing
but a name or some watch i know emilio
latino hundreds of latinos maybe not
hundreds five probably right that were
named junior they were all junior junior
but i don't know about the third the
fourth or any of that kind of [ __ ] yeah
also there's limited names
they have like seven names yeah they're
everybody's only names and latinos right
they really have very few names carlos
sanchez i i guess he's a junior
pedro juan i can name it luis hector
hector
jose jose
jesus
jesus
that's it i think they have under i i
bet you whoa
i bet you mario i know a couple mario's
there's more italian but i know a couple
under 25 names
i bet you 90 of latinos are named under
25 names male news male
even less for women maria
muslims have three names do you remember
the guy the guy comes up to us and he
goes hey what's up we're big fans yeah
yeah yeah where muhammad i'm muhammad
no can i say something can i say
something real quick
what an [ __ ]
muslim to not name their kid mohammed i
was just going to say yeah you got it 90
of them are named muhammad and then you
have to have that conversation where
you're going to be the unique one
oh my kid's name is imat
this is the name of muhammad it's mo
it's md okay like 90 of the rest of them
why do you have to be the the hipster
music yeah yeah is that how your hipster
in islam is aziz aziz
hi bro zeeshan all right we get it with
the c's dog we get it literally
everybody's name is mo everybody yeah
just go along with it ahmed or ahmad
no no we can't even do that no 90
how many one percenter named muhammad
probably let me check
99.9 probably it's unreal
i mean it is unbelievable the amount of
uber and taxi drivers that you get that
are named muhammad yeah it is
it's hacky at this point
you know what though i feel like i know
way too many andrews
i feel like it's way too many andrews
and it's a lot of alex's we got three
alex's that work with us there's no way
that you're comparing the name andrew
alex to the name muhammad i'm not
comparing talking about but if we're
also talking about overused names and
this is one that slept on andrew a lot
of andrews a lot of alex
yeah yeah
i don't think you're understanding here
we're talking about a billion people yes
muhammad way more common about 150
million boys what's the super bad line
where he's like why'd you pick mclovin
he was like well it's uh i was between
mclovin and muhammad he's like why would
it between those two names because
muhammad's most common name in the world
read a book
i believe that most common name in the
world yeah it is 150 million men and
boys named muhammad
150 million by half the u.s or actually
the full male population of the us
that's crazy dude
it's like if every man in america was
every man in america had the same name
that's not andrew alex it's not that's
not i just i'm running across a lot of
andrews and alex's i'm like i'm this
sure i'm sure there's a lot of us spend
some time in baghdad yeah it's not like
every single time you get into a car
it's by a guy named that's got to be
easy for you guys because you have a
hard time telling them apart anyway what
i'm around people hey muhammad you're
probably right
i mean you don't got to learn names this
way that's right matter of fact when you
meet a brown person is it even offensive
to assume muhammad they can't even be
offended by that now like because
they're both assuming my name is
muhammad your brother is your brother's
name why would you assume you're uncle's
name 90 you're dazzling yeah i mean no
you're right no my name is 90 right
you're right my name is muhammad i just
wish you wouldn't know it right away
in bali they named the kid based off of
the order that they're born so like the
first born has one of two or three names
the second has one of two the third is
always the
one other name and then the fourth and
then repeats itself more than four
everybody in the neighborhood everyone
you can guess if you say are you the
oldest kid all right your name is wayan
putu or geday wow
love that right efficiency you know if
you're bad with names that's the best
i'm bad with names yeah the best that's
like a uniform
like in school you have to wear the
uniform and if you go to school in
uniform you don't have to think about it
you're like oh it's taken care of yeah
when they let you pick your shoes oh
yeah that's life that's the middle name
that's the middle name you're like i'm
going with this guy what's the middle
name yeah
you